[Musique]
le 19 juin 2020 découvrez ou redécouvrez
les sentiers chargé d'histoire de lille
est à guillaume un lieu emblématique de
l'île de 1864 à 10 879 près de 200
enfants vivaient ici à 700 mètres
d'altitude dans cette colonie
pénitentiaire agricole les journées
européennes de l'archéologie deviennent
cette année arqués orama une édition 100
% numérique qui dévoile une partie des
secrets de ce lieu d'immenses murs en
pierres sèches les dortoirs le cimetière
des axes de circulation
enfoui sous une végétation tropicale
relevé numérique 3d réalisée grâce à la
technologie lidar permis aujourd'hui de
localiser l'ensemble des vestiges du
pénitencier
tous les aménagements réalisés à cette
époque mystérieuse
[Musique]
yvette à guillaume comme vous ne le
verrez jamais
[Musique]